la escritora bolso laca lewin dijo que
cualquier poder ejercido por seres
humanos puede ser resistido y eliminado
por otros seres humanos para mí esta
frase encapsula perfecto el punto y el
propósito detrás de las protestas
feministas el cual es denunciar
plantarle cara y eliminar las diferentes
formas en las que el patriarcado
oprimido violentado y explotado de las
mujeres a lo largo de la historia si
queremos entender las protestas tenemos
que partir primero de lo que las causas
nadie se levanta un día y de la nada
decide tomar las calles porque sí sino
que detrás de esto hay una razón que nos
mueve a hacerlo y que muchas veces
también nos desbordan en el caso las
protestas feministas esta razón ha sido
desde siglos atrás el atropello
constante de los derechos de las mujeres
y más recientemente también la violencia
exponencial a la que nos enfrentamos por
el hecho de ser mujeres que no se nos
pase en largo que hoy en méjico asesinan
a 11 mujeres al día sólo por violencia
machista y eso nos indigna y eso nos
causa rabia pero es una rabia digna y es
una rabia justa que nos mueve a las
calles
quizá la pregunta de mucha gente sea
bueno pero porque las calles porque no
otras formas de protesta y la razón o la
respuesta de esto es muy simple porque
ya se hacen todas las otras formas las
feministas en méxico y en el mundo lo
han hecho de todo han hecho películas
documentales escriben libros tesis
artículos han hecho performances
canciones poesía pliegos petitorios han
militado en la política tienen grupos de
defensa personal tienen grupos de
autoconciencia han hecho denuncias
protocolos leyes y aún así la violencia
persiste y cuando la violencia también
viene desde las mismas instituciones a
través de las cuales se nos pide
protestar no nos queda más que resistir
por fuera de ellas por lo tanto cuando
la violencia persiste cuando las
instituciones no sirven y cuando la
conciencia social parece no avanzar que
queda en nuestro caso y en el caso de
muchos movimientos sociales más muchas
veces lo que nos queda es tomar el
espacio público este espacio se toma
como el escenario a través del cual se
busca hacer un llamado de atención se
busca darle luz a un tema que nos urge
resolver
con las protestas también se impulsan
mucho la discusión social se nos exige y
se recuerda que ser mujer no debería de
ser un factor de riesgo
cuando ponemos el cuerpo en la calle lo
ponemos porque precisamente ya hay un
duelo colectivo es decir no necesitamos
que la violencia nos toque a cada una de
nosotras de manera individual para
solidarizarnos con quien ya ha pasado
por una situación violenta vamos juntas
en la calle porque colectivamente nos
duele lo que le pasa a las otras las
protestas son una forma de expresar este
duelo común también ponemos el cuerpo en
la calle porque queremos hacer memoria
histórica estamos ahí para hacer la voz
de las compañeras que ya no están para
exigir justicia tomamos las calles para
que sus vidas no pasen al olvido para
que la exigencia de esa justicia no pase
al olvido porque lo que se olvida no se
resuelve
ahora uno de los temas que siempre gira
mucho alrededor de la discusión de las
protestas es sobre y realmente que se
logra con ellas y para resolver esta
duda habrá que darnos un brinco a la
historia y nos vamos a dar cuenta que
los diferentes movimientos sociales han
logrado avances muy importantes tanto a
corto como a largo plazo y muchas veces
lo han hecho gracias a las protestas
pensamos en los derechos de las mujeres
si las mujeres hoy podemos estudiar
podemos trabajar podemos recibir un
sueldo podemos militar en puestos
políticos podemos denunciar cuando somos
violentadas podemos votar entre muchos
otros derechos más es precisamente
porque las feministas desde años atrás
han tomado las calles para exigir todos
estos derechos los cuales no se nos
dieron sino que los tuvimos que exigir
tomamos el caso del voto por ejemplo si
las mujeres hoy podemos votar alrededor
del mundo es porque hay muchos
sufragistas les tomo una lucha constante
de casi 100 años en muchos países ellas
por ejemplo tomaban las calles vestían
de blanco compartían panfletos se
educaban militaban sus ideas también en
los tribunales y muchas de ellas
perdieron la vida
y podemos tener este derecho tan básico
si pensamos en consecuencias a lo mejor
en corto plazo
pensemos nada más en cómo se han
impulsado distintos temas en la
discusión social hoy hablamos más
abiertamente aunque no siempre la mejor
manera sobre los diferentes tipos de
violencia a los que nos enfrentamos las
mujeres el acoso el abuso sexual el
feminicidio ya no son temas de la esfera
privada y eso es muy importante porque
no solo estamos generando conciencia
sobre estos temas lo cual nos ayuda a
visibilizar los y eliminarlos sino que
también estamos revelando la urgencia de
defender una agenda a favor de eliminar
la violencia machista
las feministas como estamos en las
protestas estamos muy conscientes de que
al final de ellas el patriarcado no va a
desaparecer como por arte de magia pero
sabemos que las protestas que las
marchas son un esfuerzo más son un paso
más de todo lo que se hace continuamente
y diariamente precisamente para eliminar
este sistema pero cuando no se tiene
conciencia histórica es muy fácil decir
que no se gana nada con las protestas y
creo que también lo decimos porque
estamos muy acostumbrados y muy
acostumbradas a creer ver efectos
inmediatos de todo lo que hacemos pero
así no funciona la historia el progreso
social es muy lento y ninguno de los
movimientos que ha buscado cambiar las
cosas a diferencia de los que buscan
mantenerlas igual ha logrado sus
objetivos desde la comodidad del
silencio o del puro diálogo tan solo
pensemos en las revoluciones o pensemos
en las independencias pensemos en los
movimientos de los y las obreras que
exigían mejores condiciones laborales
pensemos en el movimiento de los
derechos civiles pensemos en los
movimientos que defienden la tierra
pensemos en las protestas que defienden
también la autogestión de las naciones
indígenas pensemos en un equipo de wall
street pensemos en las madres en la
plaza
argentina defendiendo a sus hijos
desaparecidos pensemos en todas las
protestas de hong kong
pensemos en black light matter pensemos
en la primavera árabe pensemos en los
chalecos amarillos de francia pensemos
en el feminismo y lo que ha logrado a lo
largo de la historia
cada uno de estos movimientos no ha
terminado pero alcanzado grandes grandes
avances y muchas veces lo ha hecho de la
mano de las protestas por supuesto que
lo ideal sería eliminar todos estos
sistemas que nos han oprimido a lo largo
de la historia como el patriarcado y el
capitalismo únicamente de la mano del
diálogo pero lo que la historia
demuestra y como lo expresó también otro
error es que las herramientas del amor
nos sirven para desmantelar la casa del
amo por lo tanto cuando la violencia
persiste cuando los sistemas no
funcionan y las estructuras fracasan
tomamos las calles y si hacemos ruido y
en el proceso quizás se rompen ventanas
y se pintan paredes pero lo importante
es que se protesta no hay que olvidar
que las ventanas se reponen y que las
paredes se limpian pero las mujeres
asesinadas no vuelven y esto es lo que
nos debería indignar porque parece que
socialmente nos indigna más una pared
dada que las vidas arrebatadas
injustamente de miles y miles de mujeres
y jim wolf alguna vez escribió el futuro
es oscuro que es quizá lo mejor que el
futuro puede ser quisiera terminar con
esta frase porque aunque no lo parezca
es una reflexión muy positiva porque nos
está diciendo que el futuro está abierto
que no hay nada determinado por lo tanto
siempre existe la posibilidad de la
posibilidad lo único constante y
permanente es del cambio el futuro está
por determinarse lo que significa que
aún tenemos esa posibilidad de resistir
y eliminar el patriarcado y entonces así
movernos realmente a una sociedad más
revolucionaria y sobre todo justa
la revolución es un proceso y la
protesta es una de sus formas muchas
gracias